after a full year of lies obfuscation
misdirection someone has finally taken
dr fauci to task senator paul take it
away
what study shows significant reinfection
hospitalization
and death after either natural infection
or the vaccine
it doesn't exist there is no evidence
that there are significant reinfections
after vaccine in fact
i don't think we have a hospitalization
in the united states
after the two-week period after the
second vaccination
yeah you have a death in the united
states you're not
hearing what i'm saying about variance
we're talking about
wild-type versus variance and now
what proof is there that there are
significant reinfections with
hospitalizations and death
from the variants none in our country
zero well because we don't have a
prevalent of a variant yet we're having
one
can i finish we're having 117 that's
becoming more dominant policy based on
conjecture
there's no evidence that there's any
sort of reinfection
i'm talking about the variance there's
no evidence of infection from the
variance
well yeah not yet but maybe right so
stay locked down and wear your mask your
sheep well that's not going to work for
me fauci it doesn't work for me either
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from douglas roach
who says this is kind of it seems like a
very simple observation
but it's an important one he says the
left is a never-ending
slippery slope do you remember i want to
say 10
15 years ago we heard about the slippery
slope from the right a lot of
conservatives said you know
if you start normalizing certain
cultural programs certain bits of the
cultural revolution
pretty soon you're going to end up in a
really weird place in our country where
you've got like drag queen story hour
and we all lock down and we all wear
stupid masks all the time and we upend
our whole culture
and what did the left say oh stop it
oh you're being paranoid oh there's no
such thing as a slippery slope actually
conservatives have been warning about a
slippery slope
since the 60s at least really even
probably earlier than that
the left says oh no you're crazy you're
no what are you talking about
the slippery slope people were right
about everything every conservative
who has ever invoked the slippery slope
and been laughed at for it
was right and now we're living in that
bottom of that slippery slope right now
and by the way we're not at the true
bottom there's a whole
further way that we can slide and if
your culture is sliding into decay and
destruction you want to be prepared
which is why i would recommend ready
wise
ready wise is the leader in emergency
food supplies everything from
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online and have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep ready-wise products are
proudly made
in the usa and best of all they taste
great and they give you peace of mind
when preparing ready-wise meals all you
need is four cups of water the water
doesn't even need to be hot
you just pour the food into the water
you stir you cover you wait 15 minutes
the meal is ready
some meals by the way can even be
prepared directly in the pouch which
eliminates the need for additional
supplies
if the past year has not taught you that
it's good to be prepared in an emergency
when resources are strained i can't help
you
there's just nothing i can do to
convince you but i think the rest of us
all realize how important that is get
peace of mind this week my listeners
can get 10 off at readywise.com when
entering knolls10
at checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 30-day
no questions asked return policy there
is no risk in taking the initiative to
get you and your family prepared today
that is readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-dot
promo code knowles10
to get 10 off rand paul really just
wrecked dr fauci here you know the
classic videos i guess ben
is the typical example of this but the
videos you know conservative owns
liberal rand paul owned
dr fauci it was a great exchange because
dr fauci did what what leftist experts
do what the technocrats always do which
is say you're not
you don't understand my brilliant ideas
because rand paul says specifically
we don't see evidence of re-infection
from covid so once you get vaccinated or
once you've already gotten the virus you
can take the stupid mask off
and then facie says no i'm talking about
the new variants of kovit
right so he's trying to misdirect here
but then
rand paul says okay fine we're talking
about the variance there's no evidence
that if you've gotten covid or you've
been vaccinated against kovid that
you're particularly susceptible
to the new variants either and fauci
says okay yeah you're right there's not
evidence
but there's not a lot of evidence that
you're not susceptible you know so
therefore
stay locked down do whatever i tell you
to do even if my rules
change by the hour rand paul not having
it he says
this is government by conjecture
no you have the it isn't based on
conjecturians
so you some you want people to wear a
mask for another couple years no you've
been vaccinated
and you parade around in two masks for
show
no you can't get it again there's almost
there's virtually zero percent chance
you're going to get it
and you're telling people with them that
have had the vaccine who have immunity
you're defying everything we know about
immunity by telling people to wear masks
we've been vaccinated
instead you should be saying there is no
science to say we're going to have a
problem
from the large number of people being
vaccinated you want to get rid of
vaccine hesitancy
tell them then quit wearing their mask
after they get the vaccine you won't be
able to get the vaccine
give them a reward instead of telling
him that the nanny state's going to be
there for three more years and you got
to wear a mask forever
people don't want to hear it there's no
science behind it
what a brilliant point here from rand
paul and rand paul
has been really great in the fouchy
debates because he's kind of
the flip side of dr fauci
they are both doctors right they're
they're both
medical professionals and they're also
both politicians
and people only think of rand paul as a
politician and people only
think of dr fauci as a medical
professional but they're actually
each of them are both they both work for
the government they both get their
paycheck from the federal government
they have both worked in medicine before
and
they're just expressing different
political views dr fauci expressing the
left-wing
technocrat administrative state view
that we need to have government by
experts
and rand paul expressing the
conservative and libertarian view that
we ought to have constitutional
government by the people
and rand paul is also making a great
point about incentives here
i'm not particularly interested in
getting the vaccine
not because i'm totally worried about
you know bill gates injecting me with 5g
or whatever frankly my cell service
isn't that great so i could i could use
a little boost anyway
if i became a hot spot you know but it's
not because of any crazy theories that
you see anywhere
it's just because statistically speaking
i don't really need it i'm young i'm
relatively healthy i'm not saying i'm
totally invincible or impervious to the
virus i'm just saying
i make calculated risks every time i
walk out the door
and sometimes when i'm in my home too
and this seems like a risk i would be
willing to take
if i were 90 years old maybe i'd have a
different idea if i were
extremely overweight maybe i'd have a
different idea if i stay in nashville
long enough i will become extremely
overweight and then i would have a
different idea perhaps too
but even if i were interested in getting
the vaccine
you need to incentivize people right
as a pure personal health matter there's
not a ton of incentive for me to get it
if i'm also being told that i i won't be
able to take the mask off i won't be
able to change the way that i behave
once i get the vaccine then i truly have
no incentive there's just no reason to
do it at all and that's what fauci is
doing
and he's doing it as rand paul says for
show rand
or dr fauci will put the mask on in the
middle of a
baseball diamond where he's not close to
anybody whatsoever and then he'll
dribble that ball to home plate
and then he'll go sit up in the stands
with his friends
sitting three inches apart from them and
he'll take the mask off
people people he doesn't live with but
he just thinks the cameras are off of
him so he can behave
more normally none of the people who
want you to live your life
in terror of coronavirus are
fearful of coronavirus themselves john
kerry shows this too john kerry just got
caught on
camera he was on an airplane he goes
into the first class cabin
sits down immediately takes his mask off
he's not drinking something he's not
eating something
he just takes his mask off because he
realizes that
in many social situations the masks are
just for show right they're not doing
quite as much
as some public health experts are
telling you they do
that's actually what dr fauci told us at
the beginning they're not doing
a ton and there can actually be some
negative effects of it if you're
touching your face and you're touching
your eyes and whatever you're moving it
around all the time
john kerry gets caught doing this
that'll teach him not to fly private
he's gonna he's gonna have to start
flying private again if he does that
this is just an imposition for the
little people
but the big people violated you remember
this at joe biden
joe biden early early in office he
signs a rule saying that on federal
lands you've got to wear the mask all
the time
what does he do he goes to the lincoln
memorial he's got his family there and
people aren't wearing masks
because there's one set of rules for the
the rulers and there's one set of rules
for the ruled somehow though i love the
fouchy testimony i hope we play that on
on repeat somehow fauci's testimony was
not the worst testimony over the past
few days
the same regime that will not let us
out of our homes for fear of the virus
and tells us we have to wear 75 masks
even after we get vaccinated
is now admitting that it lets
foreign nationals into this country
without checking them
for coronavirus this rep andrew clyde
grilling the secretary of the department
of homeland security alejandro mayorkas
and he puts him in a corner can you
assure the american people
that no one who has been apprehended
is released into our communities with uh
that still test positive for covet 19.
um uh congressman let me be
let me be clear there were times
earlier when individuals
um were apprehended and we sought to
expel them
and we were unable to expel them and we
were compelled to release them
and we did not have the opportunity to
test them we have addressed that
situation
so so right now as we speak right now
you're telling me that no one is
released into our country
that is coveted 19 positive congressman
uh allow me to repeat myself if i may
well that's just a yes or no question
just yes or no no it's a congressman if
i may
uh the situation uh at the border is
complex and the complexity is evidenced
by the questions
i've been receiving throughout the
morning the situation at the border is
complex
but this question is not complex mr
secretary
have people foreign nationals been
released into our country without being
tested for covet 19.
well you know the nuances and the no
it's a yes or no question i understand
that immigration is a complex issue
this is not a complex issue has it
happened or not
yeah well we try to enforce the rules
yeah right i know that you do have have
you succeeded in that he pushes him
further i
thought this was great questioning too
by by representative andrew clyde here
okay yeah it's complex take away the
complexity for a second
can you tell me that you have succeeded
in enforcing your rules
so please if i may it is our policy
to test into quarantine okay but are you
executing to that policy 100
we are doing the best we can to ensure
that the policy
is executed 100 of the time that i can
say
this is like you know if your girlfriend
says to you you know i love you and you
say
yeah i love spending time with you
he says what no do you love me though
yeah no i
love so much of what we no
you're not answering the question do you
stop these people from coming into the
country without being tested for covet
we that is our policy okay are you
succeeding at that policy
we are trying our best uh-huh
just can you please okay i guess your
non-answer
is an answer the same regime that is
absolutely
intent on keeping you from going out and
seeing people and having thanksgiving
and having christmas and going out
without the
the secular kefia all over your face is
allowing foreign nationals to enter our
country without being tested for kovid
during a pandemic that's the sort of
thing that
might make people not sleep so easy at
night but if you do want to sleep easy
at night you should check out
helix sleep everyone is unique and helix
sleep knows that so they have several
different mattress models
to choose from they got soft they got
medium if you're anything like me they
have the firm mattresses that's what i
prefer
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot they even have a helix
plus
mattress for plus size sleepers if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz
you order the mattress that you're
matched to and the mattress comes right
to your door shipped for free you don't
even need to go
to the mattress store you just forget
about those mattress stores helix is
terrific
you also don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick
of 2020 and by gq and wired magazine
just go to helix sleep dot com slash
knowles know wlas take their two minute
sleep quiz
and they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the absolute
best sleep
of your life i really really love my
helix it was so easy to get by the way
the way it was shipped
and really uh terrific to sleep on
they're offering up to 200
off all mattresses and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
knowles that's knowles 4 helixsleep.com
to 200
off and two free pillows go check it out
even
democrats are calling out the
the absolute madness that's going on
at the border even uh
because what they're doing here is
they're not
trying to enforce the law
they are incentivizing law breaking this
guy
mayorkas the the secretary of department
of homeland security
is out of one side of his mouth saying
look we're really trying to enforce the
law and
you know we're doing our best and please
give us some grace here but then out of
the other side of his mouth he's saying
also people should come to the border
maybe not right now but they should
surge to the border because we're going
to let them in and we're going to give
them amnesty
if you say to them this morning do not
come
the next question is going to be how
long do i wait
and what am i waiting for is there going
to come a moment where you say okay
now is the time
in weeks in several months we will
expand the legal processes that we
already have started
to rebuild we already have reinstituted
the central american miners program
that was built in the obama biden
administration and that was torn down
by the prior administration but we well
understand
that out of desperation some children
might not wait
some loving parents might send their
child to traverse mexico alone
to reach the southern border our
southern border
i hope they don't undertake that
perilous journey but if they do
we will not expel that young child we
will care for that
young child and unite that child with a
responsible parent
that is who we are as a nation so do not
come now
but come in like 15 minutes if you
if you that'll solve our problem right
it's an
incoherent policy it will increase
suffering for everybody not only is it
unjust in itself
because it breaks these laws and these
are just laws
that a country ought to be able to have
its own borders america
is has the most open immigration regime
in the world and that's still not enough
for some of these radicals but also
just in terms of the personal suffering
that everyone will undergo
when you incentivize illegal immigration
you
empower cartels you empower coyotes you
empower
smugglers there was a study that came
out some years ago from fusion and
huffington post so you're talking about
left-wing outlets here that said that 60
to 80
of women and girls who cross that border
illegally are raped or sexually
assaulted on the journey
even from a purely only focus on the
migrants
you know humanitarian perspective pretty
vicious stuff
but the left is encouraging it because
they want a flood of of migrants into
the country
because they know that they are going to
overwhelmingly win those votes
whether or not the they have a plan for
amnesty for the people who are crossing
illegally
but even if they don't get it there
they're still overwhelmingly likely to
win those votes
one and even two generations afterward
and this is because of birthright
citizenship
when when this is too much for
democratic representatives
in congress you know that the left has
gone quite far
a representative raul ruiz democrat from
california
says the biden administration just not
doing enough
when it comes to immigration uh
president biden saying
very clearly in an interview don't come
here
to migrants is that enough
you know no that's not enough i mean one
is it's very important that people
realize that we're in the middle of a
pandemic and that it's not safe for them
especially with the cartels and the
coyotes that are taking advantage of
them and re-traumatizing them
during the journey so he i was actually
coincidental i i didn't remember that he
had made that point but it's the same
point that i just made
which is you you when you're
having have these lacks policies that
are supposed to be aiding
the migrants what you are doing
inevitably
is empowering these vicious gangsters
who are brutalizing not only our country
not only americans but also the migrants
themselves
vicente gonzalez democratic
representative from texas
saying this has gone too far democrats
need to stop
this crazy policy the coming across
the the the rio grande river and being
processed and released into our
communities
cannot be the norm uh our cities and our
counties
on the border don't have the resources
to deal with this and and
it's a federal government's
responsibility it puts a lot of pressure
on our local governments and our local
communities
and we're in the middle of a pandemic
where every one of us has lost somebody
who
who we love and i've as i said i've lost
over 3000
uh constituents in my area i've lost 11
personal friends and family members
we've been ravaged here in south texas
and we need an orderly process to assure
our safety and our health
absolutely now why is are these
democratic representatives speaking out
here i think it's pretty clear it's
because they're from border states
and so these issues are sort of
immaterial
to people in new york in northern
california and chicago i mean you see
illegal aliens
end up there and so it does create
problems but
it's very different up there than for
people who are right there on the border
seeing the realities of this every
single day
and seeing how much worse the problem
has gotten because of the policies
of president biden but is it really
president biden who's pushing these
policies
you know i've said from the very
beginning i don't think joe biden is a
person
i don't think he's a human being i i
think he is a suit
and then there is some sort of matter i
guess that fills the suit and kind of
you know
it has the form of a human body but he
is just
in effect this empty suit and when he
wakes up in the morning he licks his
index finger he puts it up in the air he
figures out which way the wind is
blowing
occasionally the the combination of joe
biden's
vacuity and his incompetence you know
his uh tendency to have slips and gaffes
combines in a really hilarious way for
instance when
joe biden referred yesterday to
president harris
must be matched with fairness and equity
now when president harris and i took a
virtual tour of a vaccination center in
arizona
that was nice that president harris took
you on that tour that was nice that she
she picked you up you know allowed you
to come out of the
the house for the day get a little fresh
air which is good and then obviously
take you
take you right back to it a great line a
lot of people have drawn a comparison
between
joe biden and the late soviet dictators
reagan used to joke that he wanted to
reach out to them but they kept dying on
him you know they were just these
figureheads they were very old they were
not particularly effective
does this mean that kamala harris is
running the show maybe i
it would seem that she's exerting some
influence here and joe biden refers to
her as the president
even on the campaign trail he was he was
making references to her as the
president
but it's it's more than that it's not
just this wicked kamala harris pulling
the strings
it's the whole edifice that the reason
that joe biden is able to be a
completely empty suit
is because he is merely an avatar for
the liberal establishment
he he is in many ways a return to normal
the normal is not a normal that we like
namely corporations
with no loyalty to our country upending
our culture
uh people pulling away any sort of
immigration controls that we have
upending law order i mean it
but unfortunately that was kind of the
normal that was being pushed
by this establishment and it would seem
that even joe biden
is admitting this speaking of mistaken
identity
to show you where the slippery slope is
going a man in canada not in the united
states but in
our neighbor to the north america's hat
robert hoogland from surrey british
columbia
is now spending time in jail because he
referred to his daughter
as she he
called his daughter 14 year old daughter
she
and now the supreme court of british
columbia
having ordered this girl to receive
testosterone injections
the court is now uh ordering him to go
to jail
finding him to be in contempt
14 year old people you'll know are below
the age of consent
they can't consent to do very many
things if they want to work they have to
get certain permits if they want to have
sex they're not allowed
to do that if they want to have certain
medical procedures they need parental
consent
because they themselves cannot consent
that's the premise of
law agent consent laws but if this girl
says that she's a boy not only can she
get these hormone treatments
the courts in canada will insist that
she get those hormone treatments even
over the objections of her parents and
if her parents continue to object
the court will throw those parents in
prison this began
because the girl's school urged her to
see a psychologist
who then recommended that the girl take
the hormones this actually began at age
13. and then the doctors at the
school which is run by the government
right decided that the girl should
receive the testosterone injections
and then the father couldn't say boo
about it this is the slippery slope
this is not some some foreign you know
way across
the seas dictatorship that's so unlike
ours
this is a government that's very much
like ours and that is just further in
the direction of progressivism and this
sort of thing
is not so far down the slippery slope
from what we're seeing
here you know
when i want to see things a little bit
better
i need really good glasses and that's
why i turned to coastal at coastal.com
you can get prescription glasses
starting at nine dollars with free
shipping and
60-day risk-free returns plus they have
the most advanced virtual try on
technology that you will find anywhere
turn your frames into sunglasses by
testing out colored lens tins or finally
see what a cat eye or aviator would
really look like
on your face right now with your phone i
think the cat eye looks very fetching on
me
but your mileage may vary with coastal
you don't have to spend
hours at the store or hundreds of
dollars to get a new style just go to
coastal.com
pick the frames you want enter your
prescription details and your glasses
will arrive in just a few days i got to
tell you the try on technology
is really amazing it's not just like
some you know glasses in the middle of
the screen and you fit your face to it
you can move your head around it shows
you what it looks like on the side it's
really really great stuff
makes online shopping for glasses so
much easier it's that final thing i
think
that you really need for online shopping
for glasses for a limited time they're
offering our listeners the best
deal they've got going on anywhere 30
percent off your first pair of glasses
at coastal.com
michael mich ael get free shipping
60-day risk-free returns and 30
off at coastal.com michael discount
applied at checkout only for a limited
time
c-o-a-s-t-a-l dot com slash michael some
restrictions apply
the problem of the slippery slope is
that
all societies have standards we're
always going to have some standards
and when you start knocking down our
traditional standards
very often there's no limiting principle
to that
so you just are in free fall and you
have no argument having destroyed the
old standards you have no argument
for stopping the cultural radicalism at
any given point
the question is what standards are we
going to have wheaton college
showing this craziness wheaton college
which is a christian school
is removing the word savage from a
plaque that it had up honoring
missionaries
the the plaque was honoring these
wheaton college missionaries
who went in to the savages of the jungle
these tribes that were living in a very
brutal and savage
way and these missionaries were killed
by the savage tribe but that's not the
end of the story
the the end of the story is that the the
families of these missionaries
continued their work and extended
christian
love and grace to them and now
they love one another that many of the
tribesmen did convert to christianity
the story
has a happy ending these people had been
harassed by the shell oil company and
had been killing oil company employees
trying to keep those employees
from entering into their territory
the shell oil company had gone to the
ecuadorian government
and convince them that if they wanted
the shell oil company to find oil
that together they had to get rid of
this problem
so dad and his friends decided to try to
make a contact a friendly contact
before efforts were made to try to wipe
this small tribe
of violent people out
in the process dad and his friends were
killed but that's only the beginning of
the story
a usa today editor when he was
interviewing us said you know i can
understand
possibly forgiving the man who killed
your father but he said but loving him
that seems almost morbid and you know it
would be if it wasn't true
wow oh my goodness what an incredible
story
what a christian story
this is the story of the spread of
christianity which wheaton college ought
to defend but they are very upset about
the word savage the word savage
refers to the woods that's the etymology
people living in the woods
this tribe living in the woods
wheaton college very upset because it's
it's offensive to the indigenous culture
those missionaries were offensive to the
indigenous culture because they went
into the
jungles into the woods and said hey you
savages should stop living
in in this way which is pagan and
missing out on the good news of the
gospel that we are bringing you
oh my goodness could you imagine if the
wheaton college administrators heard me
say that they would be shocked and
horrified
but guess what many of these tribesmen
these former savages
would agree with everything i just said
that's why they converted to
christianity
what we are saying here what what
missionaries used to be able to say
what our whole culture used to be able
to say is that it is better to be
civilized
than to live in the woods moreover it is
better
to believe the good news of the gospel
than to believe whatever crazy pagan
religions you were believing before
because it is more reasonable
it is not merely an act of will we the
missionaries imposing
by force our will on you that's not what
they did at all they gave their lives
trying to spread the gospel and then the
children of these people came up and not
only forgave
their people who murdered their parents
but loved them
and through this kind of love you see
the spread of christianity
that that's what happened it wasn't just
will it was reasonable and
some of these people reasoned and made
an act of faith
to come to christianity a wonderful
thing but the college doesn't understand
what its purpose is anymore because we
are losing
our sense that you can rely on reason
you can do do all
sorts of things speaking of savages have
to get to this story before we get to
mailbag
a wisconsin children's court judge who
previously ran an lgbtq organization
that fundraised for drag queen story
hour
among other programs was arrested
tuesday
on charges of child pornography
stop the presses i'm absolutely shocked
i couldn't possibly be more surprised
that some degenerate pushing drag queen
story hour
which is transvestite's twerking for
little toddlers at a public library that
he might have some
kind of weird sexual preferences and
fascination with children
shocking isn't it no it's not shocking
at all brett blum
according to reports from the german
milwaukee journal sentinel was taken
into custody by special agents with the
state division
of criminal investigation following an
investigation into multiple uploads of
child pornography
through a kick messaging application in
october and november
uh brett blaum is gay and probably the
most
disturbing part of this whole thing is
that he and his partner have
a two adopted children i believe so
really really worrisome stuff
can we just agree to get rid of drag
queen story hour
can we just agree that where there's
smoke often there is fire
can we just agree that it is not a
blessing of liberty
to have transvestites twerking for
toddlers at the public library
conservative every conservative and and
just about every democrat
would have agreed with this 10 years ago
not that long ago but now because the
slippery slope just has a sliding on
down
because of that even many conservatives
now will say you know well if we
ban drag queen story hour then they
might tell us we can't go to church
they're already telling you you can't go
to church they've been telling you that
for a year in many places in this
country
and and by the way if we can't
distinguish in this country
between twerking for toddlers
in drag and going to church if we if we
think those two things are basically
kind of the same right we can't
make a moral judgment between them then
we can't make any kind of moral judgment
then we can't have any kind of political
vision because self-government relies on
the ability of the people
to to make these kinds of judgments for
themselves
and then implement that through
self-government another leftist leader
of dubious morals
before we get to the mailbag sir major
page 32 years old was just invited
indicted rather he was invited to go to
prison by a federal grand jury in
cleveland on three counts of money
laundering one kind of wire fraud
according to the doj
page is uh the leader of the black lives
matter of greater atlanta facebook page
uh he created a 501c3 non-profit
organization for this group
he raised almost a half million dollars
from donors
and you know how he spent that money
that was being given to him oodles of it
being given him for social justice
and racial justice he spent it on
his house on guns and on hookers
it was always a gift it was always a con
the blm organization
this is why the family of michael brown
and ferguson and other community leaders
in ferguson
are now demanding tens of millions of
dollars from the blm organization
because they want a little cut of the
action they want a piece of this
extortion ring that blm has been running
on corporate america and many other
people
for well over a year now it was
always a naked power grab some people
gullible gave into it
others did not meanwhile when they're
not blowing the money on guns homes and
hookers
they're spending it to burn the country
down through the riots that we saw
for for six to eight months in this
country
quite a slippery slope could you imagine
telling someone that this would happen
five ten years ago they wouldn't have
believed it the only way we're going to
stop these things is if we make
substantive moral claims which is an
argument i make in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
available for pre-order until amazon
figures out what it's about and then
they'll take it off all right
we've got to get to my favorite time of
the week the mailbag go check out ben
today
who talks about uh ways to stop this
kind of cancel culture
says that the cancellations will
continue until morale improves also
the michael knowles show youtube channel
crossed half a million subscribers this
morning
can't believe it folks i really
appreciate it we put a ton of extra
content
on that channel uh so head on over there
and subscribe to the youtube channel
some people have told me that they
subscribe and then
for whatever reason they get
unsubscribed from the channel so who
knows why that would happen on a big
tech platform
so head on over if you haven't
subscribed already and maybe even if you
have
go check out and make sure that it it's
still there also candace
premieres today uh candace owens new
show at the daily wire it's
shot yesterday it's super cool it's
unlike anything we've ever done
this is exclusive to daily wire members
you know for a lot of our shows
you can see most of it or listen to most
of it if you're not a member
candice you've got to be a member to
watch it head on over do not miss a
single episode of candace
go to dailywire.com subscribe use code
canvas for 25
off dailywire.com subscribe use code
candace
for 25 off we'll be right back with the
mailbag
first question from anonymous general
knowles i'm in the military and have
mandatory cno directed
extremism training next week i don't
know what will be said or discussed
but i think we can guess given the
events of the week i would like to voice
my conservative perspective
but am fearful because cancer culture
here includes legal action
under the ucmj this uniform code of
military justice
any advice from me of note kendy's book
how to be an anti-racist
is on the cno's professional reading
program that's unbelievable
uh as well as other extremist books
thank you
it's it's very sad to see this
one great benefit of the trump era i was
actually chatting with a
military friend of mine last night one
great benefit of the trump era
is trump exposed
the bureaucratic leftism
of a lot of the officer class i think
there are plenty of good
military officers out there i think
maybe it's even most of the military
officers
maybe it's most of the enlisted guys are
good
ordinary patriotic american people who
believe perfectly conservative things
but a lot of people who have attained
power among officers
and even among enlisted guys like that
wacko from space force the other day
who was yelling at tucker carlson a lot
of the guys who have risen
and been able to attain positions of
power both the officers and the enlisted
men
are left-wingers they're
and i don't just mean left-wingers in
the way that we always have a left and
right in the country i mean
radical left wingers who are seeking to
upend our traditional american culture
guys pushing
the the racialist theories of even
ibrahim kennedy and
all sorts of people like that that's a
big problem and i think a lot of the
conservative impulse to just give as
much money as they want to the pentagon
oh pentagon wants a ton of money yeah no
no amount of money is too great i think
we've got to check that a little bit and
recognize that
all bureaucratic institutions
have a tilt toward leftism and because
the left has waged
in the words of the communist theorist
and leader antonio gramsci
a war of position for the last 100 years
a topic i mentioned in my book at length
speechless
because of this war of position they've
attained a lot of power in the
universities
in hollywood in the media in the
administrative state
and even in the military and so we need
to reform that i'm not the sort of
person who says we need to rip
everything out root and branch
i think we need to go in and have the
culones to uh it's a little
italian-american for you
uh cojones at the very least to be more
polite
to exercise political power when we get
political power
and it's very difficult thing to do
particularly with the military because
it's
so big it's so entrenched in many ways
the traditions of the military have
helped it from going completely off the
rails
but the radicals are trying to transform
it very difficult stuff
my friends just don't know you know some
have walked out of these trainings
but done it in enough of a way that they
won't get in trouble for it
but it's a very fraught political
problem right now the only answer is
going to be political
reform from abraham hi michael
are you jealous of matt's obvious beard
awesomeness or can you grow an equally
amazing beard and are just hiding the
skill
i am man enough to admit that i cannot
grow a particularly convincing beard
you know it's a little sparse it's even
a little bit patchy
i can grow a mustache in about 25
minutes
but that creates a big problem because
you know i give a lot of talks at
schools
and when i grow the mustache it's a
court rule i'm not allowed within 300
yards of any schools
kind of like that guy you know the the
guy who was the court judge who
who ran drag queen story hour i start to
look like one of those guys so i can't
i just can't pull it off okay if i could
pull off a washi type beard or even
better the spencer clavin square beard
i would do it if i could pull off the
tom selleck mustache i would do it some
people are meant for facial hair
others are not from lyanna hey michael
what would it take for individuals to
pull a christie gnome join together and
give the stimulus checks back
i have to believe there are enough smart
savvy people out there to know
uh what this money actually will cost
and would choose to give that fourteen
hundred dollars back just so their
children grandchildren wouldn't
eventually have to
a statement that uh that of sorts that
clearly showed that some of us can't be
bought
i'm not gonna give the money back if i
don't know if i'm getting a stimulus
check i think i actually am supposed to
depending on which what tax year and how
it's all these kind of byzantine rules
if i get a stimulus check i'm not going
to give it back
i appreciate your impulse to do that if
i could
create a world in which we took the
budget seriously and didn't just enslave
our children to endless debt
and actually tried to pass on an
inheritance to our children instead of
just destroying the inheritance that
we've received
both culturally and financially
i would i would do that but
unfortunately
this is a strategy that republicans have
pursued for a long time and it hasn't
worked
namely to play by the set of rules that
we want everyone to play by
while the other side is going to play by
their own set of rules
that doesn't work that's that's just
unilateral disarmament
and uh i'm not gonna do that i'm not
gonna say all the conservatives give up
your money but let the left-wingers get
their money no that's just an even more
egregious transfer of wealth
to the left i wouldn't do that at all uh
how do you transform this sort of thing
i think what we need to do
is deal in the real political
circumstances that we're in right now
and we need to use every advantage that
the left will give us
to crack up the left and that's not
that's not a
purely abstract feel-good
way to understand our political
principles but our political principles
which
exist in the abstract have to be applied
in real life
if they are going to have any sort of
weight to them any gravity to them
and that's what we need to do now i
think that was a lot of what the trump
era was about too
is you had a lot of people clutching
their pearls when trump
was nominated because they say no this
isn't
the principled way of mitt romney and
john mccain
it's not the way that we princip in a
principled way lose
right it's not it's not but it would be
better to win
in a way that maybe discomforts you not
in a way that's immoral but in a way
that maybe discomforts you a little
bit than to lose in a perfectly
wonderful way
from joy hey michael the mainstream
media is shocked shocked
that the catholic church is in fact
catholic and follows scripture and
tradition as they have for the last
thousand years hypothetically what could
catholics do if a pope was elected
that ignored scripture and tradition in
a blatant attempt to be more culturally
relevant specifically
if a new future pope was chosen that
allowed blessings to same-sex unions
hand-waved abortion and all the other
items from the world's wish list would
we see another era of three popes at the
same time do catholics have a form of
civil disobedience
if the papacy went blatantly unbiblical
well there are ways to question the pope
there are very prominent cardinals
members of the episcopacy who have
raised
dubia doubts that the pope would
should answer and pope francis has not
done that
you can even politely charge people with
with heresy uh pope has not responded to
those things either and so that's all
perfectly acceptable
we've had bad popes before we've had
heretic popes
for goodness sakes and yet the church
has survived that
so hillary bellock great catholic writer
a great conservative writer highly
recommend
everyone read hillary bellock he he had
a good line on this he said that i am
required as a matter of my faith
to hold the catholic church divine
divinely instituted and divinely guided
however one bit of evidence for those of
you who don't believe that
is that no other institution conducted
with such
navish imbecility would have lasted a
fortnight
that the catholic church is run so
poorly
by such flawed men and that has been the
case
sometimes worse sometimes a little
better for 2 000 years
that the real wonder here is that the
church has survived
and survived as it has intact
that to me is an evidence of of divine
guidance
catholics believe that when christ says
i i will always be with you i will not
leave you uh you know it
obviously he ascends up to heaven but
that he will always be there that
he will send the holy spirit and that
god will always guide the church
that that means that no matter how crazy
things get
uh there will the bark of peter will
still remain afloat so
i do believe that there are mechanisms
in place to question popes but
you know even so much confusion from
pope francis's pontificate
somehow the church remains afloat even
in these crazy times from liam dear
professor koffe
is it too late to hope that
conservatives will wield political power
when they have it
after the uh nothing strange happened
here
results of the last election with
election integrity deforms being pushed
through
at the federal level and with fears of
ending the filibuster
packing the supreme court and turning
washington dc and puerto rico into
states
is there any hope the conservatives will
ever win let alone wield political power
in the future yeah i think there's hope
but
the prospects are getting worse and i
some conservatives want to remain
complacent and say oh it's fine it'll
swing back
it'll be okay no that's not
that's not always the case political
parties come and go
sometimes certain political parties have
dominance
for decade upon decade upon decade
think of the dominance of progressives
and the democrats in the early 20th
century it shaped
the world that we have today think about
uh the way that these these parties can
change the structure of government
such that it's very difficult for us to
win again i don't i don't think that it
there's a world in which it becomes
totally impossible for
republicans or conservatives to win
again because what what would have to
happen in that case
is that the regime would have to become
so corrupt
that it would have to rule basically
just by the imposition of its will and
you're seeing
traces of this now no one's ever allowed
to question the election
even though you had prominent democrats
including barack obama
raising worries about election integrity
measures not that long ago now you're
not allowed to do that
and big tech is going to censor you and
if you question the regime's views on
transgenderism you're gonna have your
books kicked out of the biggest
marketplaces in the world you know it's
it's trying to close in and grab on it i
think that's evidence that it's a
somewhat weak regime
but yeah it could persist for a long
time i think it's important that we win
in the near future
and that not not only that we win but
you actually have to to do things it's
great to drag mark zuckerberg to a
hearing and yell at him but
you know that in a buck 50 i'll get you
a cup of coffee you actually have to
reform these things
hold their feet to the fire and if you
don't do that a lot of politicians are
bought off by these guys anyway
but if they if they can't do that then
yeah probably probably we have lost for
the near future
from matt dear mr knowles i sent you a
question last week
regarding what you think the best
argument against christianity was
i thought your answer was very
thoughtful and so i have a follow-up
question if you're willing to entertain
it namely
what do you think is the best argument
against catholicism
and why do you think it falls short love
the show keep up the good work
i think the best or i don't think there
is one
good argument against catholicism i
think there are lots of little arguments
against catholicism
that brought together uh create in
people
a sort of disposition against
catholicism
it was said i forget who it was it's a
very famous statement and i'll just i'll
attribute it to ronald
ronald knox but i don't know it's one of
one of these sort of great catholic
writers
maybe it was john uh uh
gosh i don't know i forget there are so
many so many people john henry newman
who knows
who said that there are not
a hundred people in this country who
really hate the catholic church
there are millions of people who hate
what they think to be the catholic
church but
there aren't that many people who
actually hate what the catholic church
is so for instance
the catholic church as chesterton
pointed out gets attacked for opposite
reasons
it's attacked for being too ascetic you
know you flagellate yourself you fast
you you know that's too ascetic but it's
also attacked for being too luxurious
the gold of
of saint peter's you know all the ornate
iconography and
architecture so which is it it's
attacked for opposite reasons
it's attacked for being anti-woman
you know keeping women pumping out kids
and you know in the kitchen or something
and it's attacked for being too too
womanly to for only
having women show up to mass and the men
don't show up as much so which is it is
it
is it misogynistic or is it feminist or
who you know
what is it uh there are arguments
against the church because they say
catholics worship mary
catholics don't worship mary they
venerate mary and we ask mary to pray
for us
but we ask bob down the street to pray
for us too and so does everybody else
uh it gets knocked for the saints i
suppose that would be the same
the same idea uh catholic church gets
knocked for pushing a
a salvation through works theology
uh but it doesn't and actually that that
heresy which is called the heresy of
pelagius was condemned by the catholic
church many many moons ago
centuries and centuries ago in the very
early part of the church it's condemned
for being founded by
emperor constantine you know centuries
after christ lived
uh that just isn't true and you can read
the you can read the uh
documents of the early church fathers
and and references to the catholic
church and
you can see that development you can
trace the the papacy all the way back to
saint peter and then linus and then all
the guys all the way up to pope frankie
right now
so i i don't mean to be flipping here i
do think there are lots of
it's what jeremy might call the
preponderance of false evidence
there are all these little arguments
that people make that that had very
successfully turn them away from
the catholic church but i just think if
you examine any of the arguments
specifically they don't really hold up
let's take one more question
from hannah hi michael i've been unable
to avoid hearing about sarah everard
murder several times a day
she was killed by a man while walking
home at night sparked a lot of debate
surrounding women's safety
and has even made leftists concede the
biological differences between men and
women
a baroness in the house of the lords
even proposed a 6 p.m curfew for men i
don't think women should be scared of
all men
but just that we should generally be
wary of strangers especially at night
it's clear to me as a young woman that a
concealed carry permit would be useful
here i hate living in a country with no
second amendment i was wondering what
your thoughts are much love from the uk
my thoughts are i totally agree
there will be order there will be rules
imposed it's a fantasy to think we can
just all do whatever we want all the
time
and that there will be no consequences
to licentiousness so the order will
either be from people who can protect
their own liberty and defend that
liberty with
wonderful blessings that we've been
given in our politics such as
the second amendment or it's going to be
imposed by a government that that might
not have your best interests at heart
great intuition that's our show i'm
michael nola's the michael knowles show
see you next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 hey everybody this is andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin